buongiorno a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
sia questo nuovo video sono vari generi
siamo sulla parte ii mi tormenta souls
gioco tipo residenti vol
old school molto molto figo buona
visione perché merita un sacco suo gioco
let's go
devo ricordarmi assolutamente dove sta
perché c'era una porta che si apriva
solo elettronicamente quindi adesso
dovrebbe essere aperta teoricamente
aspetta questa che sono alieno cosa devo
mettere questa tipo che è però in
compenso che comunque prima o poi lo
aprirò non adesso
anzi qualcosa qua libreria locker from
the other side bel quadro allegri meno
ma leghista ospedale ci sono quadri
allegri mi sembra poco il quadro giusto
ammettere in ospedale complimenti
ragazzi veramente designer interni
veramente pop poi ospedale moderno
almeno quello aperta maternità
attenzione ok chiodi anche quella
perfetta scatola rossa con i proiettili
residenti vol quindi perfetto
ci sono un sacco di medicine io non ne
ho neanche uno anche se mi servirebbe
come va tagliato la faccia la parte
sinistra lin cuore di plastica non vedo
che è oggetto più utile potrebbe
arrivargli sono questo tensione ma e
marca per l'asta co per cortesia tanto
lo accesa adesso ma cos'è manca il cuore
eccolo qua a posto ma volevo metterlo
intero mancava parte d'altra parte va
bene e quindi defibrillare lo dopo che
lo metto va bene così almeno mi lascia
il la manopola farci è roba macabro
cazzo diventato è diventato sarge un
simulator 2 così ma tua sorella silvia
lì dentro ma veramente male
parliamo ma per quale arcano motivo
dovrei ficcarli qua dentro abbiamo
ragazzi l'altro pensa il paziente che
dormiva vicino a quel letto lì che c'era
sotto una botola concas che avrei
dormito io ok c'è un nastro con delle
informazioni chi ha uno specchio
oddio no perché c'è qualcosa dietro
kabul santa madonna benedetta non c'è
qualche ci sono più cose che mettono
l'ansia
va bene che devo fare qua anno deve
accendere le candele che tale che è che
è successo ma poi c'era la luce cosa
centrale candela fare non toccare o tipo
narnia solo con lo specchio rotto tra
l'altro già porta sfiga cliccati ficcati
non vedo cosa può andare storto ficcati
nello specchio perfetto
io io veramente non so di che cazzo
gioco fa
ok siamo entrati nell'aldilà va bene
oddio tanto c'è un precipizio nove
ragazzi sono entrato nell'altro tipo
seguenti sentito rumori non mi piacciono
tensione che è capitan a ciò che
successe ma sputato stu struzzo del
merda è morto volte ma sempre cosa sei
morto grazie gentile koucher ritrovare
una rob una cura
oddio giorno mi se aveni che dovevo
metterla lui corre finto allora sento
ancora musica di combattimento messi
combattere ma tipo una cosa per curarmi
le erbette dire sentivo e non certo
perché non so però benissimo nove
ragazzi di andare in giro che l'ospedale
così emas e pazzi r sì va beh minchia
non posso aprirla media meno male che
brutto è solo nove ragazzi alibi lettera
sono fai qua c'è un'altra come chi sia
presto cosa devo forzarlo in qualche
modo raga prova a tornare indietro
perché non ho capito effettivamente dove
trovare c'è devo trovare qualcosa per
aprire la porta a colare porca [ __ ]
non è questo sembrava centrano cosa per
forzarti paul non so dell'olio ed a
ficcare sulle ingranaggi non ha idea con
quache era un'altra porta magari questa
che c'era riuscita alla fine waiting
room sento gente non ho colpi ma non ce
lo vedo caricare vabbè non ha visto
sono 21 andato oltre i colpi di mano
meno male con altri chiodi credo che qua
si sa quel che dice devo trovare
qualcosa qui che sono non solo non mi
spiego o pace qualcosa un'altra porta
dentista maron immagini a raggi xe el
più è scritto con i corpi cosi dentro un
paziente va bene cioè è impossibile che
qua dentro non ci sia nulla da piccolo a
l'ingranaggio della portale prima ho
capito lo ficco qua perfetta sulla
chiave è completa ma hanno scarse come
dove devo girare i pezzi vita che casino
wicker certo si vede proprio che dice vi
state impegnando usate da o vista lei
liste york pur wicker katz kerr all
altro pezzo del cuore perfetto orari
misco ok e ma ora che gli unici devo
trovare qualcosa effettivamente voleva
dal mettere altamente nell'altro
paziente non voglio non voglio tirare
via il telo ma non lo fare quantica
strofa ok che figata
va bene e me ne vado arrivederci va bene
allora vado a ficcare a parte viola
chiave completa
ok e poi ho il cuore del paziente che mi
serve per trovare una novella dice una
paura che lo sapevo sento gente sento
gente sento gente ho sentito ho sentito
gente non mettevano nascondetelo sentita
c'è qualcuno da qualche parte lo sento
porca [ __ ] 2 sul sito maroncelli
prima testa no ma locai careca madonna
questa carica mentre circolava sposta di
prima spostati santo iddio non ci credo
sta male
uno scherzo verso uno scherzo è uno
scherzo
ppa per il tour li pigliano per il culo
per il curve c'è un altro modo per
colpire i nemici si copia di porco
minchia che volta è morto melo vale meno
ma nemmeno in è venuto in mente di poter
equipaggiare piedi porto meno male
meno male perché qua c'è qualcosa adesso
sicuro che hanno ficcato un tizio che
mia non c'era
non c'è niente o sono combattuto a caso
contro un tizio va bene va bene prima di
andare sotto voglio vedere se riesco a
ficcare la chiave della porta perché
quella porta lì ne sa c'è la porta c'è
una porta dove praticamente poi ficcare
una chiave 200 gli alieni disegnati
sopra gianola eccola qua a va tra
l'altro sia spacco questi ma che ci son
proiettile anche presidenti non ho
peccato che ci ho creduto un'ascia
allora qua c'è un indizio dall'altro
pentagono e il tipo soldato va bene però
non capito che tipo di inizio del resto
facevo
ma chi allora porta e questo c'è la
chiave questa non so però come la devo
ficcare allora alieno tutankhamon e apre
slate o ha girato circa 62 mila
combinazioni come agente la prima polito
alla fine occhio che bene o tiro in
testa da capo
minchia ragazzo ha messo due ore
combinazioni infinite va bene
ci mancava solo mancava il posto al buio
grazie stessa roba ott medico forstale
più allegro degli altri cosa sono organi
va bene quindi a action and so che ti
missing and o meno capi tutto
sostanzialmente devo prendere ok questo
quadro devo pre allora assente da me
devo tornare dove stava il neonato
ficcarci cuore poi lui mi darà qualcosa
il paziente mi dà la manovella piccola
novello agosto col e apro la porta
se funziona questo mondo se non
funzionano zoe micol più da donna aiuto
maternity se ragazzo stava magari
materni che proprio perciò bisogna
andare lì sotto perché qua c'è una porta
anzi no la porta sta proprio di soft
mica che casino mi devo fare così
entrare qua dentro madonna e bordello
l'agguato ma che brutta poiché gioco è
però che non ci sia per ora speriamo in
incontrarvi nessuno più colpito era
finito finto tutti condono più colpi
dico solo questo
allora qua sta al cuore per forza questo
100 105
e sembrato vivo per un momento
mandami qualcosa tipo si dovrebbe essere
svegliato più o meno giorno ok
ecco vedi a posto fantastico che dottore
la kalex che grazie alla lorella lo zio
tutto sto casino per una manovella di
merda combina e adesso devo usare questa
roba combinata con la porta che sta dove
che stava dal dentista quindi devo
andare da sempre sacrosanto di gesù
cristo sentito un rumore non mi è
piaciuto chi è
scusi ma devo andare lì sopra non so se
di tomorrow nostri avversari non mi
ricordo più dove il dentista raga aiuto
a michael più d'altra parte forse porca
portanza qua qua questa dentista uscita
waker on
giusto per me questa è questa
e questa pacifica ma lo siamo ha visto
qualcosa muoversi su steam su maledetto
c'è un royal kink ratio per the royal
king cage fantastico in tappeti
imperiale risultano tacite cosa questo e
abbiamo aperto anche la claire redfield
schael la sala principi il salone è mica
filmatino il mattino allegro proprio per
noi che ce lo siamo meritato
madonna per quanto fatto bene solo
pazzesco pazze ma che giocò pazzesco
raga credibile la verità si nasconde
sottoterra dove la luce non può
raggiungerla se ti e piaciuto alla demo
per favore non dimenticarti di bue
wishlist arci sting grazie per giocare
giocatori signore signori che dire gioco
pazzesco pazzesco bellissimo attualmente
il solito qui sugli stato sostituti
quanti ragazzi perché proprio figo non
vedo l'ora di giocarlo versione full vi
chiedo scusa se ero un po bongiovanni
rispetto al solito perché sono un pò in
febbraio trova però non sono potuto
veramente tantissimo quindi mi dispiace
se non o se non ce l'abbiamo c'era un po
strana bellissimo comunque bellissimo
gioco magari speriamo che nel gioco
mettano un'arma che siamo più seria una
sparachiodi cioè quello completo di
signori però che mi sia piaciuto questa
tormente so se mi è piaciuto consentirà
certamente mi piace il commento da sotto
e noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video solo se trovo telecomando eccolo
qua bella ragazza
[Musica]
no